Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday, May 1st, 2017 what's going on?
How do you like that echo?
I am in my garage. This is what it's come down to.
It's like fucking a quarter to seven or 10. Seven in the morning.
I got to go to the airport. My lovely daughter is sleeping,
my wife is sleeping. There is no place in the house for me to scream and yell.
So I'm out here in the garage and oh by the way,
in less mild but an hour around eight o'clock.
There's people coming to my house cause um, well, you know the gas line is,
I dunno, 96 years fucking old.
So that thing needs to be replaced because it's leaking all over the goddamn
place. Um, that's always fun to have a baby in your hands.
You set it down towards the floor and you'd have to say things to your wife like
, um, do you smell gas? So, um,
getting that taken care of today and uh, this is it.
This is where my life is at. So I'm sitting here
on my workout bench that uh,
I can't use cause I fucked up my shoulder gradually getting better.
This is the longest, most nagging fucking injury ever to try to heal.
But I'm almost there and um, this is how I'm going to do what people,
this is how I'm going to celebrate.
This is the 10 year anniversary of the Monday morning podcast.
Can you believe that for 10 years I have been yapping to myself,
you know, 10 years. I have not been reading 10 years.
I been making up shit for 10 years.
I've been saying shit that I thought was true cause I heard somebody say it in
an airport. I've been doing that for 10 years. Um,
I want to thank everybody who's been listening. Um,
and I'm going to put a link to a post,
whatever the fuck you guys say. It's,
it's a thing that you click on and then it goes to the video that you want to
watch, which will be the, um, the first Monday morning podcast ever,
which I believe was about 90 seconds long. I'll give you a little history.
I was over a Robert Kelly's apartment back.
We still live right around the corner of each other.
When I was still living in New York City and I was over his house and he was
just, you know, it was typical Bob. He was just like, kid. Yeah,
you should do a podcast.
This isn't to May of 2007 one of the few things I've ever been at the beginning
of podcasting and getting a special on Netflix.
Those are the two things I was at the front. Like I remember, you know,
for my intro and comedy clubs, I would say a, they look,
what do you want to say? Oh, let's say he's been on this. He's been on that.
And you can see he might've seen his specials on Netflix and the host would say
it and people would snicker. They'd laugh in the crowd.
They'd laugh at that credit. Well, now look at it. Huh? Look at the, the,
the fucking world dominating behemoth.
You know,
there's oil companies now that look at Netflix like, God damn,
how the fuck did you do that without firing a shot?
How the fuck did you do that? Right. So Netflix,
Netflix, and podcasting know if I was, if I was in an oil company,
I would, uh, I said I would do,
I would start coming up with some original content, you know what I mean?
And just make the show so amazing, you know,
that the stars would then go over to those countries and while everybody was
fighting over the cast of the reboot of friends,
I would then run around the corner and I would start stealing their oil. That's,
that's how I would do it. You know, it's a lot less messy, you know,
there's excitement. Am I going to get caught? Right? Um, anyways,
back in the day, so I'm over Robert Kelly's apartment. He's like, dude,
you should do a podcast. And I was like, what is a a,
what is a podcast? [inaudible] it's like a Jib recording.
It's another way to connect with your face. You, who knows?
Now people listen to it and you're singing, Yo,
you doing the stretch factory Tuesday to Sunday, dude.
And I'm literally just fucking around on it. And I actually, I called it,
if you listen to my first podcast, you listened to the link. I actually,
he said, I said, uh, this is my podcast.
I was basically repeating everything that Bobby was kind of yelling to me in the
background. And um, and I called it,
I said a and who knows,
maybe this might lead to something mediocre and you know what it took might have
taken me 10 years, but God damn it, I got there. Here I am
sitting here and my fucking garage.
This is not some sort of cool reverb that you listening to.
This is me and my garage.
Um,
you know what's amazing though is I gotta tell you something.
I don't know what it is. It's, I'm such a cliched guy.
I fucking love the garage. The garage is the shit.
You know what I mean?
It takes you back to being a single man when you barely had anything.
Cause I have one of those fucking garages. By the way,
I was not going to be the person that had the garage, right. That like, Yup,
my shit. And there's no more room for this shit in your house.
So then you take some other shit that you used to like and you stick it in a box
and then you stick it in the garage, right.
And gradually it starts encroaching on the car and next thing you know,
the car can't be in there and it just fucking fills all the way up.
But you know what you're doing. You're slowly becoming a fucking hoarder.
Yeah.
That's one of the saddest things I, yeah. Actually, you know,
I came at and understand whether it's sad or whether it's, um,
you just taken responsibility for,
for all this shit that you buy in your life. You know,
I guess anybody could take it down to goodwill.
Anybody can throw it in the trash, take it to the dump.
Okay.
It takes a real caring,
you human being a real caring human being to just sit there
and in, in, in all the fucking shit you bought your entire life.
Every fucking newspaper, every tube of toothpaste,
just sitting there suffocating in your own fucking carbon footprint.
Okay.
You know, I just realized, you know, we shouldn't be looking down at orders.
We should be looking at these people going like, Holy Shit. One human being,
what human being can buy all of that shit and alive.
It's not even a lifetime. They still live in, you know,
you can have that many pets, fucking fish tags,
newspapers and all of that crap. Um, I dunno,
I would happen. I'm sitting there looking over right now. You know,
my neat little fucking garage. I got like two different brooms.
I got this old fucking mop. I don't even know where that thing came from.
I think it came with the house, you know,
and I've been meaning to throw that thing up or where does it end up?
Fuck it in some beavers house,
some stupid mop handles sticking through his little fucking fetch of a roof.
All those things fast, by the way. I get those giant Goddamn teeth.
Fucking horse teeth, dude. It's so they can cut through the back dude. Anyway,
so it's been 10 years and, um, I'm actually, you know,
I had people on Twitter send in some of their favorite moments,
which I'll be reading later if I could somehow get this fucking computer to work
while I'm out here. Um, yeah. So anyways,
let's get on with the podcast. So I, I didn't know if I even said it.
Thank you guys for listening, uh, throughout the years.
Thank you to everybody who's booth advertised on the podcast,
whether you liked the read or you didn't,
whether you got upset and said that, I'm never going to advertise again.
Whatever it was, it was fun. A lot of fun.
So here's to the next 10 years, I'm still not going to read,
right. I don't know, whatever.
You know what I liked though? I'm a buck 76 right now.
I do like Dat away 176 pounds on roughly the fucking way that was,
that's probably a few pounds later, but I got to get down to it.
I got to get down the end of the month. Next month, my birthday,
I want to be like one 71 71 right? You know what? I get down to that weight.
I get down to that way. Guess what Dan? I'll be happy. Aha.
Then it'll fill the void. You know when I go on,
I put my little fucking tiger woods golf shirt on even though I don't fucking
golf.
Okay.
Anyways. Is that fucking guy ever going to win another tournament?
It really bugs me.
Really fucking bothers me that there's a bunch of broads out there that think
the reason why he never won another fucking tournament was because of the
bullshit of his personal life. Give me a fucking break.
His body broke down. That's what the fuck happened. This guy's a
champion. Do you understand what the champion could do?
A champion can block anything out.
If you see these guys going up trying to hit the fucking free throws,
everybody just waving their hands,
screaming a bunch of shit about the guy's wife. What did he tell? Do?
Nothing but net. Nothing but fucking net. You know, sky can't handle.
A little spat gets hit with a golf club.
He jumps in his escalate and he hits a fucking Rose Bush and all of a sudden,
all of that talent goes away. I don't know. I don't buy it.
I think, and I think the reason why some women,
some women look at me being a little measured in the next 10 years,
some women, the reason why I think they attributed to that is because I,
you know,
I think that they want to buy into that whole fucking thing is behind the Ivy
League man is a good woman. You know what I mean?
Which is so fucking stupid, right?
Obviously if you have a happy fucking marriage, your life's going to be alright,
but that's just another fucking, you know, everybody's always stealing credit.
Are we set up as a Hollywood thing and you get into a relationship. It's,
everybody's fucking sits there. Oh, now I'm laying down. There you go.
Now the back's better. Now the fucking back's better.
I don't even want to talk about, um, tell anybody.
Watch the Formula One race from soul cheek in a, in Russia.
It's such a weird name. So cheap. That sounds like a more like a,
like a Chinese or Japanese, Vietnamese Sochi.
That does not sound like Russian de Edo. A store of VA.
So Ci, that sounds too happy to be Russian,
but I have to tell you it was a fucking, that's a what? A gorgeous city that is.
Huh? You know what I mean? I mean, Russia scares the shit out of me.
I grew up during the, the end of the Cold War,
so I just figured you're going to go over there in a second if you have any sort
of, uh, I dunno. American shit on, it's just, you know,
I remember being in Finland being in this cap and it blew my mind how close I
was to Russia. It's like,
why I can't believe I'm this Far East in the Europe.
And I asked the guy if he'd ever been there and he started telling me about
Moscow, how it was, you know, a little dangerous after five, you know,
and I'm disliking. I just did the math in my head. It's like, alright,
this guy's saying it's a little dangerous. Finland beat Russia,
Finland defeated fucking style. Okay?
Stallon whose those fucking people ran over the Goddamn Nazi army with their
Mercedes-Benz fucking tanks right there.
Portia jeeps.
I can't name one fucking Russian car.
Alright. Just the sheer will and toughness of those people, you know?
Yeah. We hear those stories of them fucking,
they're running around in their socks in the middle of a Russian winter.
Just run in the fucking German army. Right back to Germany. You know?
Where else would the German army people go back to? Well,
I got to retreat back to Poland. God knows they fucking took that over. Right.
So I'm thinking, you know, take a beat. These guys, Jesus Christ,
what, how the fuck would they lose to Finland? You know,
that's the championship match right there.
That's Cleveland verse the Warriors Finland. I mean, I was looking at them like,
all right, that's the fucking warriors verse. I Dunno the Phoenix Suns,
but the uh,
yes,
I dunno, they fucking be, they fucking kick their ass.
But what sucked for them was at the end of the war when Germany lost Italy fell
and all that shit, when the axis powers lost,
they were on the wrong side of the fucking table. So they went down with them.
It was like a co op, you know what I mean?
Like if you pay off your shares in the building, you're like, all right, oh,
my apartment. It's like, no, you don't, you own shares in this building.
But if everybody else goes belly up, the whole fucking thing is done.
And then you lose your shares.
You have to go back to renting your apartment or you have to fucking leave.
That's what it was like. And that's what happened to them.
They paid off their shares in the building in Italy.
Germany went fucking bankrupt. And uh, next thing you know, that was it.
And they had the giveaway,
like the southern part of their fucking country or some shit.
They had giveaway basically the stadium in which they won the game.
They had to give that to them. I'm pretty sure that's what the fuck happens.
So anyways, subset and they go, this is,
this is the DNA that this guy comes from. And he's telling me that after five,
it gets a little fucking scary. These are people that fucking, you know,
looked old Yosef Stalad in the fucking eyes, you know,
fucking kicked his ass. They were like, we're on fucking cross country skis,
cross country ski CPT sons of bitches and this guy's nervous.
So I was just like, wow,
okay.
It's gotta be a scary fucking place over there.
And then I'm watching the f one race on so cheap.
Right.
And, uh,
it was fucking beautiful and look like a Ron Howard film starring Tom Hanks.
You know, you had a beautiful city in the background.
You had went into a forest and he had mountains and little snow caps on top of
it. It looked like a postcard. Like when they take a postcard of Los Angeles,
you know,
like once a year it's clear enough where you can take a picture of the downtown
La Skyline and then see snowcap mountains in the background. Right?
Cause they always say that, you know,
you can snowboard in the morning and be surfing in the afternoon.
And if you're in La, you looking around going, where the fuck can you snowboard?
It's cause you can't see, you can't see through all the fucking pollution. Um,
so anyways, so I'm watching this goddamn race from south cheese,
right?
And um,
I gotta tell you f one f one figured it out so far,
four races in another really exciting race.
I Dunno what happened.
They made the tires 30% bigger and all of a sudden there's more fucking grip.
But the downward force, all this shit that they talk about,
and before every frigging race, I dunno what happened,
but all I know and Ferrari made better cars. Now all of a sudden it's a,
at least you got two teams race and Ford is supposed to last year or was just a
Nico and uh, Lewis Hamilton. So anyways,
congratulations. I hope I say, speaking of Finland, Ope, I say this guy's name,
right? Mercedes-Benz, a tier two driver, the upstart,
the Tom Cruise of days of thunder, right. Uh,
vault Valtteri bought us out by said that, right?
And he's like one of like nine finished drivers to ever win a Formula One race
in congratulations to him. Joe of great race. Uh, Sebastian Vettel from Ferrari,
second place, Kimi row.
Raycon in broken in Sydney is raking in Kimmy. So Ci, Kimmy,
Kimchi, Kimmy Reagan in for Ferrari came in third,
and then Lewis Hamilton came in fourth. And I can tell you right now,
he wasn't happy. You know, he wasn't happy.
That guy doesn't give a fuck if his car doesn't work. He doesn't get,
he'll fucking run his own teammate off the fucking track.
That's what I, a little I know about that race.
All I know is if he's not winning and his teammate can win,
he doesn't give a fuck. He's not getting out of the way. You know, he,
he just doesn't give a shit. Um, but then he also wins.
So whatever. Uh, so I guess that puts a,
the fuck's his name. I always fucking up Sebastian Vettel is in first place.
He's got, I think he's got two wins in two second places. So you get 25,
25, 18 and 18. So that's 50 and 36. You got 86 points
and I think, uh, you know, I'm in the garage, dude.
I don't have the fucking internet as far as I remember.
I think Lewis Hamilton has one victory two second places in a fourth.
So that's 25, 18 and 18 and Jesus Christ, what's that?
61 36 and 25 set 61 I'm going to say it's 61 and he's got a fourth place where
he give her fourth place, like 15. I don't know. He's got like,
I don't know if we'll say 76 or some shit. I don't fucking know.
All I know is it's shaping up to be a great year and for whatever reason,
even though I have German blood in me and no Italian blood,
I actually am rooting for the Ferrari.
It's just because last year was it got boring. Mercedes won every fucking race.
So it's good to see Ferrari back. Um, and by, by the way,
shout out to force India.
I think they came in eighth and ninth of sixth and seventh.
My fault for having the balls, they have pink cars out there or Fuchsia,
whatever you want to call them. You know, they've been Mike, my, uh,
my other team, like I want to see one of them win a race this year.
I want to see a pink car when a fucking race.
It's just funny to me. Um, so anyways,
I don't even know where the next race is. I would look it up usually, you know,
if I'm not fucking laying on the floor of my goddamn garage,
I would know where the next, uh, the next race was.
I know there's probably a lot of you going like bell,
why the fuck you getting into is first of all, it's a great fucking sport.
Second of all, it doesn't take a lot of time to watch. There was 52 laps.
It said, you can very easily add that, you know,
to whatever sports you watch. And I'm telling you even during the NBA,
in the NHL playoffs, cause I fucking watched everything. You know,
I want you to St Louis Blues Right this weekend.
Watch them winning over time. Getting to believe was game two.
I watched so much shit this weekend. I watched a the last two games,
Anaheim versus Edmonton. Um,
amazing to see Edmonton like all of a sudden looking like, wait a minute,
these guys are going to be the western conference champions,
the way they're applying and all of a sudden they get the old right there.
Fred from the fucking ducks in Edmonton,
one of those weird series where they're three games in and the home team has yet
to win. Let it children going home crying during that series so far,
and I'm, I hate to say this is a Bruin fair, but fucking Lou Cheech,
he looks right in that uniform and I get a feel and he's going to stay there for
awhile. I don't know what kind of contract he signed up there,
but, um, Jesus Christ, he's looking like the old Luke cheese,
just a fucking force in nature.
I remember when he would like fucking bring it over the Blue Line and he thought
he had control of it, but he didn't.
And he'd sort of just be kicking it in and she wants somebody else's trying to
like fucking stop them. You just give him a little fucking forearm.
The guy would fall down,
he'd pass it over version run and he'd score out and she's,
I missed those days anyways. And then watching that,
of course I watched the Celtics fucking
since
the old sports rivalry that most of the sports world does not realize is a
fucking rivalry. These two teams hate each other.
But you know the deal, it's all about the fucking golden state warriors.
It's all about the Cleveland Cavaliers. And um,
so no one's really paying attention, right?
No one's paying attention to these two fucking people. They know. It'd be like,
you know, you got the rolling stones and the Beatles and everybody's so,
oh my God, they're fucking amazing. And then meanwhile,
Herman in the hermits doesn't get along with the fucking partridge family.
I don't think were that bad.
I'd like to think that we're not that bad. But, um,
anyways, so the first game,
like it give you a little bit of a background for a stupid reason.
Earlier this season, the wizards were like,
we're going to dress all in black when we play you guys codes. It's going to be,
it's going to be like a funeral. I was like, oh,
Gigi h is that what you're going to do? And then what are we going to do?
Try, are you going to try extra?
And that extra hard tonight fucking wizards. Right?
So even with that stupid little fashion statement that they made,
they still beat us. So, but not because they wore black,
they beat us because they scored more points. So anyways,
so we're getting ready to go see them. Uh, we're getting ready to play them.
And um,
my buddy Josh at a Mys from the Goddamn comedy gym and from the Comedy Jam,
they had to clean it up on a comedy central.
We decided that we're gonna go down to a cigar bar and we're going to watch the
fucking game together. He's a big wizards fan and uh, and he's a,
she's a Shit Talker, right? Three's been talking shit, you know,
cause I think they won this. Uh,
I think we beat him like once and they beat us like three times.
I can't even remember. And he was talking all this shit.
And at one point they were ahead of us in like the rankings.
They were number two, we went up to three or something like that.
He was just talking all of this fucking shit.
So the game starts to Gar bar doesn't open till 11 game comes on at 10.
So I'm sitting there watching the fucking first quarter.
They go up two to nothing. It's five to nothing. Seven and nothing.
Nine to nothing. Fucking 1216 and nothing case. You missed the game.
You don't have fucking sports center or whatever. 16 to fucking nothing
to start the game. Annual. The game is, it's over.
If it's any sort of illegitimates I will, legitimate sport.
This game is over and I gotta be, I gotta be honest with you,
I will never like 100% be able to believe that that basketball is not fixed.
I don't understand it.
I don't understand how one team can spot another team's 16 points.
You end the first quarter,
one team's on pace to score 120 points or some shit and the other team's on pace
to score 20, like 75 or some shit, right?
Well, whatever, 80 points or something. And somehow it just, it's always,
it's a gable runs.
Then out of nowhere they started like 16 to nothing.
And then we go on like a fucking 25 to eight run and somehow the scores tied or
we're up by like two with the half. I don't know. I went,
I drove to pick him up and then we, you know, went over to the cigar bar.
So there's a lot of Chit chat going on. And um,
by the end of the third quarter, we were up by 50.
We were down 16 nothing, 36 minutes of basketball later,
we're up by 15 a 31 point fucking turnaround.
Like, do you ever, when the bills came back against the Houston Oilers,
this basically that that happens just about every other game in the NBA.
I don't fucking get it. Oh, it's a game of runs. It's a game. Is it?
How does one team come out? Ice fucking cold. The other team can't miss.
And then like,
like I've never had a set where I go on stage and it's just like I'm on and then
all of a sudden I'm off and then I'm on again and then I'm off.
That's what happens. Basketball.
So we're up by 50 Josh is losing his fucking mind.
He's standing up, he's pacing,
which is hilarious because it's a garbart supposed to be like totally Chili's
fucking pacing back and forth.
He's slamming down fucking slices of pizza, you know,
like doing like stress eating and I'm just laughing. I was just going like,
Josh, it's the fucking NBA. This game's going to be like,
now we're going to do the fourth quarter. And because the third quarter ended,
the switch gets shut off and the other one gets flipped on.
And what this is going to be at fucking tie game.
So what happens fourth quarter starts,
the fucking Celtics can't score a bucket for like the first four minutes.
And next thing you know,
like the wizards at down by three and is sitting down again.
And I'm just laughing. It's like,
how many fucking NBA Games do you have to watch?
Which you really do if you just want to,
if you really get into the games and you feel like you're gonna fucking die a
thousand deaths, what you should really do is just watch the last two minutes.
God knows that takes as much time as the first fucking 46 minutes.
Just watched the last two minutes because it's going to be like a fucking three
point game anyways. And um,
whatever the ebb and flow and then some other Celtics pulled away again. But,
um, I gotta tell you it's gonna be a fucking brutal series, brutal series.
And I think a Jake Rado might get kicked out for one game.
This can be some sort of physical altercation.
I don't know what's going to happen.
I've been looking into my fucking crystal ball. I don't know who it's gonna be,
but somebody's going to get fucking kicked out of the game. Uh,
gets suspended for a game cause he's fucking teams hate each other. And uh,
you already started to see it happen a little bit in the first game. I just,
they just don't like each other, but I gotta tell you some,
I actually love that John Wall guy. I love when, uh, uh,
Josh showed me this fucking, uh,
whatever the fucking Instagram picture or something like that.
I guess a couple of years ago they lost to the, uh, Atlanta, um,
the fuck are they at the hawks? The Atlanta Hawks? Yeah.
Saint Louis Hawks to the Atlanta hawks. Right. They lose to them.
And one of the guys on Atlanta, you know,
they had a picture of them in the final seconds of winning.
And John Wall has a real sad look on his face to do the posts if it's real
happy. And then there's another Lana Hawk looking at John Wall laughing at him
and uh,
I guess John Wall didn't forget about this. So when they beat Atlanta,
he posted a picture of him, you know,
doing a crossover in the gal posted the picture, fell on his fucking ass.
I love people that hold grudges like that. I think that to be great,
you have to be like that, which is why Eli Manning is such a fucking enigma.
You know what I mean? I swear to God, like if you saw that guy in the most,
in the final two, two minute offense of a Superbowl, his heart rate, yeah.
Is the same.
Is somebody at a fucking bake sale right outside of church.
You know what I mean?
Oh, he, thanks for coming out. Oh look how big your kids are getting.
That's his heart rate is,
you know, I swear to God, they,
she just seen all those dockers he's always wearing with the fucking sweater
tucked into them.
They should just make a uniform just to completely psych out the other team.
If I was the giants side, he'd have like a special pair of football pants. They,
they'd be the same color as dockers. He'd still have the pads and shit in it,
but you know, some sort of dad jeans.
So anyways, I think the Celtics Wizards is going to go, uh,
I think that's going to go seven and I think it's going to be fucking brutal.
I think a, the wizards when the next one and then I think we split down in DC.
I think it's just going to go back and forth, back and forth, back and forth,
um, that, that evenly matched. And um, I don't know what I was,
forget the guys name, that fucking Polish Transylvanian dude,
the white dude with the shape tant whose entire body is his fucking heart as the
top of his goddamn head. I mean,
that guy looks like he could have played like fucking professionally,
could have played like at least three different sports.
Okay.
[inaudible] fucking plates, some gigantic fucking tight end. You know,
he's there. His body, he's like fucking white. Lebron. I know, I know.
Go on a limb there, but I'm telling you that guy, he's a fucking beast.
I was joking with Josh Cohen, his dad fucking grew up in eastern Europe.
His Dad probably fucking beat him with one of those fireplace. Pokers all right,
we're all laughing. I was sitting there going like that. That can't be the name.
There's gotta be a different name for the four fire fire, police, poker.
I'm just saying what it does that can't be the name.
And I looked it up and that's exactly what it's called.
Okay.
Fireplace poker. That's the best they could come up with.
They couldn't come up with some widget name, you know,
even with like the ladies, they got that thing they put in their hair.
Somebody came up, what's it called? As called a Flowbee. Oh, what? Yeah.
Flowbee
the fuck is a Flowbee at something you stick in your hair.
That makes it do a couple of woopty dues. I don't when I'm talking about,
let me do, um, let me, uh,
let me read a little advertising here and then I'll talk about what a sad time
it is to be a Washington DC fucking sports fan. Jesus Christ.
All the fucking crying these Cleveland fans did.
Did you ever see a city cry as much as they did? Oh,
we should fucking miserable. I mean,
maybe they did that in Boston back when we were, weren't,
weren't fucking winning, but I always hated that shit ever. A long time ago,
ESPN did this hope they wouldn't have some trial.
Like who has the more miserable fucking sports fans?
Cubs fans are red sox fans. I remember sitting at home laughing going, dude,
I don't want them. I don't want to win this. You want to be more,
who fuck wants to be the most miserable?
Um,
you know who those fuck the kind of person you'd want to run into when a goddamn
bar. You know, going to sit there and just talk about how life fucked him over.
Sorry. Anyways, let me read some of the, some of this advertising here.
Oh my God. It's that time.
It's that time of year when you can say,
I got to get something for mother
pro flowers.
Everybody talk about how being a mom is often, uh,
often a thankless job and mother's Day is a chance to show your appreciation.
Um, I think that's talked about enough, isn't it? It's always, you know,
I want to see if they have that copy for father's day that it's a fucking
thankless job. Let me tell you something right now. All right. Is,
is difficult a job is being a mother is you fucking babies are obsessed with
you. My daughter barely looks at me. She just looking at me, she smiles like,
Hey, there's that guy that I kind of know, but my wife walks in a room,
she just like, she just follows her all around. She says looking at her,
I'm like, Hey, hey other parent, other parent over here, Yo Yo.
You know what I mean? You know like when you're at the,
at the game and they're thrown free tee shirts into the crowd, right?
And you're standing up and then there's a group of fucking hop.
They caught chicks and shit like, like you're getting a tee shirt.
Does it stop you though? You still stand up fucking flailing.
Your arms never happens. Um,
so evidently for some reason being a mom is a thankless job.
Even though everybody always talks about how important the job is.
There's not one presidential election that doesn't go by where they don't talk
about it. Everybody's always saying, you know,
mothers are saints and all of this type of shit. You know,
what do they say about their, they, they say nothing.
It's like put both on the same record label, but only their album gets hyped.
You know, when our fucking do, nothing manager's going like, yeah,
you promised us at least one billboard
east of fucking vine. You know, you can't even give us that. Um,
but evidently I have to do it again. Oh Jesus. You know,
you just can't fucking thank these divas enough.
These mothers out there.
Is there anything worse than we listen to a woman say she lost herself in the
relationship. You know, and then you find that, you know,
it's one thing if you just, you know, if you don't have kids,
but if a woman says that and they have kids right there,
you know what a terrible mother, she deserves no flowers.
But the rest of you ladies listen to this.
When you send the 100 blooms for mom boke, bouquet, bouquet,
whatever from pro flowers, this mother's Day,
you will make a real impression. Oh yeah. Now your mother's going to love you.
Look, Susan, how they work in the sibling rivalry into this. He's fucking,
people have no shame over their pro flowers.
It comes with a free glass vase for just 1999 piece of shit plus shipping and
handling. And if you really want to make a statement,
you can upgrade a premium to a premium vase and include gourmet chocolates for
just $10 more gourmet chocolates for 10 bucks. Okay?
Uh, choose to deliver. You want to buy this f one car for fucking $11?
Is this the wheel of fortune?
Back in the day for $26 I'll take the brass bed frayed.
I'll take the cuckoo clock for 18 I'll put the restaurant a gift certificate.
You know what a year supply of Trident Gum.
Choose the delivery date you want and pro flowers are guaranteed to arrive fresh
and beautiful and stay that way for at least seven days or your money back.
The only way to get 100 blooms for mom with a free glass vase
starting@nineteenninetynineistovisitproflowers.com.
Click on the microphone and right at the top right corner and use my code bar.
That's pro flowers.com and code burrow. When you click on the mic,
this studying bouquet bouquet sells out fast. So order today,
this is a great deal. What this thing is,
they act like this is the one thing you need to get your mom. It isn't.
This is like at least the thing you got to get few months.
This is a great [inaudible] to something else. Um, I do it every single year.
It's nice and fucking easy. And you know what? Your mother loves flowers.
You know why? Cause moms are dreamers. They believe.
They believe that their husband's not gonna come home hammered.
This is the time Angela's ashes. He's not going right to the pub.
He's finally going to take my kid to the doctor and figure out what that fucking
eye infection is. You guys ever read that book? Angela? Disastrous.
Jesus Christ. You know,
you thought Charlie Brown had a bad trying to kick the football.
Fucking poor bastards waiting for their dad to come home with the money.
Never came home. Went to the ghost. You know,
spoiler alert goes to the pub every fucking time.
All right, Sherry's berries.
Everybody talk about a mom you really admire and why?
Well, wouldn't that be
my mom? I'll tell you, as much as I love my mom,
there's a mob down the street. She just has those intangibles.
Mother's Day is coming up and Sherry's berries.
Was that like some politically correct thing?
Like talk about your mom. Well,
what about what if the podcast Ma mom's dead? What about that? We want to,
we'll fucking avoid that shit. Mother's Day's coming.
Everybody and Sherry's be Aries is offering huge, freshly dipped Straub, very
starting at 1999 plus shipping and right now you can double the berries for $10
more. Pick your delivery date,
and these berries are guaranteed to arrive fresh and delicious or your money
back. You may think you've seen gourmet dip strawberries before. You know what?
I got to tell you? There's a lot of things I think during the day,
and that was not one of them. I don't even know what they look like.
I don't even understand why they taste so good. We'll go fuck figured that out.
God bless the person that did because these things are delicious.
I will tell you that. Um, but you have,
but you've never seen anything like these. Sherry's berries are huge, sweet,
juicy, and covered in decadent topics.
Chocolate chips, chopped nuts,
white milk and dark chocolate and goodness Jesus,
this is getting gross.
Sherry's berries are an unexpected gift that will put a smile on mom's face.
Holy Shit. Did you drop 20 bucks on me? That was unexpected surprise.
The mom in your life was Sherry's berries at our office. Slash. Workplace.
You can't send chocolate covered strawberries to your mom at work.
Everybody's going to think she's having an affair.
The only way to get amazing Barry's deal
starting@justnineteenninetynineistovisitberries.com click on the microphone in
the top right corner and use my code bar. That's Barry's, B, e,
r r I e s.com Bravo, echo, Romeo, Romeo,
India, Echo sierra.com and my code bar.
When you click on the Mike, this amazing deal,
it won't last long and mother's Day is right around the fucking corner,
so be sure to order now, I believe it's like May 14th this year.
So if I was you,
I would just knock this out right now and then wander into a mall and find
something else that she can get her. You know what I mean?
The fucking Dutch oven or some shit. What does she do? Does she cook?
Do people even go to malls anymore?
Well, you just go to amazon.com I have to go into my fucking website,
go into the podcast page and clicking on the Amazon link so I get a little doe.
Ray, me sit my, wait, sorry. All right, here we go. Oh, look what's here.
[inaudible] me [inaudible] getting ready for mother's Day Badu too to
[inaudible] me on these. Drop your drawers and she'll say, hey,
yank up your velvety underwear drawers.
Stop shaking your ass. They'll figure Romeo whore
when you put on your Randy's for mother's Day.
I don't know why I'm singing about my mom with me.
Auntie Barbara Dabba Doo Doo to whatever. All right, Mandy's.
Everybody may undies. You need a place to stick your chocolate cupboard.
Fucking strawberries right next to your own berries day ago and then fuck and a,
there you go. Come in pelvic pumpin on mother's Day and see how she likes that.
All right. Why don't you do that this year? Just fall on the fucking knife.
So every one of our other, I,
every one of your other siblings can look like a great kid. All right.
Jesus Christ. Phil, how do you sell underwear after that? Well, I don't know,
but we're going to try. All right.
Elevate your underwear game to the next level with me on DC.
You've perfected your wardrobe, but what about this stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been settling for store bought underwear,
five packs. If you've been settling for,
go to those prepackaged priests sound together. Fucking underwears.
I have something that will change your life for the better me undies.
What is me undies? I'll be, I needs me undies.
Velvety fucking underwear. Badu do to me and these Mandy's,
take your balls out and everyone stares. Look at this as a 10 year anniversary.
You're getting two songs. Rob Nuts up against the modal.
Grabbed your dog by the fucking throat.
I'll throw it outside because it took us shit right next to your underwear
drawer and then go to jail for animal cruelty. Narrate me.
UNDIES are designed in La, La, Louisiana. Los Angeles,
who knows and made from sustainably sourced micro modal,
bought out of fabric three times softer than cotton.
Beyond the softer than soft luxury.
Unders come in and ever changing selection of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns so you can tailor your Andries to your own
personal style. I think this is why Richard Simmons actually disappeared once.
He could start ordering fucking velvety,
soft different underwear every fucking day. You know what I mean?
He probably is like, well,
I can't wear these Kandy stripe fucking shorts anymore. And that's my look.
You know what? I've made enough fucking money. I'm out. All right,
and guess what? You can save time and money there.
Frog in my throat all of a sudden. And guess what?
You could say time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for scription but then go fuck yourself.
Stay with your regular goddamn underwear, you piece of shit. No, I'm sorry.
That's, that's not the copy. If the, I'm sorry, if you're not ready,
that's okay. Completely different direction. You can still save.
That's because me undies is our, for you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burn and get 20% off your first fucking pitch.
So go ahead. Revamp your underwear drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's me. undies.com/burr Mandy's dot com slash
Berg B and e's me undies. Re revamping your underwear drawer, Bill.
Do two to me. Undies me undies. Get some fruity panties. You whore.
They make them for the ladies, for their twats. If you don't have them.
Ah Shit, it fell apart. stamps.com everybody I, you know, sent it.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm fucking sending my a fresh pair of me undies out
to Cleveland Hilarides or I'm going to be this Tuesday and Wednesday.
Um,
I use Mondays whenever I'm pouring myself out selling posters and I'm a moron if
I can figure out how to use that little device.
God knows you can't a stamp save your time and money,
which you can use to grow your business, right?
Yeah.
Well do whatever you want. You know,
watch your favorite clip from fucking a stroke, race. Whatever you want to do.
I can mail any letter,
any package you suggest a Mac computer and printer and the mailman comes and
picks it up. Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes right under like unlike that fucking whore you used to
do.
Okay.
No, I'm saying this rug was her legs. Never close.
I'm like that prude.
This is just gone off the rails. stamps.com never closes.
Print postage letters or packages
at your convenience. 24 seven, seven days a week. Convenient, easy, reliable,
flexible.
No need to Noni to lease an expensive postage meter right now you can enjoy the
stamps service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without any longterm commitments. Jesus Christ.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburkethatstamps.com enter [inaudible]
stamps.com never go to the post office again.
There you go.
You like that person that graduated high school and never came back to their
hometown and for some reason thinks that their success because they didn't.
You know you don't, it makes you a success not leaving your hometown.
It's how you treat people and you know something that's wanting to grow on.
All right. Before I get into the questions here, let's talk about, uh,
the Washington sad sack. Washington DC sports fan. You know what I mean?
After all this fucking shit about cubs fans, red sox fans,
fans of Cleveland Sports. Meanwhile look at fucking Washington DC.
Oh, they have nothing national thing when it's shit.
The Redskins have been a fucking joke,
a fucking joke for 25 fucking years. I know what you think. We'll build.
They went three fucking super bowls and the previous basically 10, 11 years.
Yeah, but she knows something. They got some racist logo on the side.
There was always something to take it away. You know what I mean?
Where this thing ever,
they had some black guy dressed up on the fucking native American head dress,
maybe had some Indian blood in him. I have no idea. Native American blood,
whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
You know the capital's how many times they go on the president's trophy get
bounced out in the second round. They've won the,
they won the president's trophy three times since 2009.
And every time they'd lost in the second round.
And they've dropped the first two fucking games and I was watching the end of
this series at home against the Pittsburgh Penguins,
the reptilian ice water in their veins. Pittsburgh Penguins,
who I'm telling you right now going on and they're going to win this second
Stanley Cup in a row. You heard it here. You heard it.
Now you play it later and you will agree with me or you don't have a combat
fucking podcast again. No, no. I think they're just going to repeat.
That's what it is. They're all dialed in. They got filled castle.
They got Crosby, they get the fucking, they got a fucking mocker,
Andre Flower, whatever his fucking name is Theo fucking flurry.
Whatever the goaltender's name is, he doesn't give a shit.
He's out there fucking doing the old fucking jazz hands stop and everything.
That's common, right? Mark Andre Flurry,
they got Gido. I mean it's they this, they're just going to overpower you.
It's it or
does Washington DC with their capitalist.
They rise up from the ashes in somehow figure out a fucking way to win game
three. I was watching the NHL network. This guy was going off going,
this is the biggest fucking game in Washington capital's history.
And I agree they got to do this, they got to this. And if they don't do this,
they're gonna blow up the whole fucking team. It's going to be sad.
They have to start all over again. Jesus Christ.
How do you not root for the capital's and game three? You got to do it.
I'm going to be rooting for them to Sidney Crosby.
I tell I've been saying this for your Sydney prize. We use backhand.
It has more fucking velocity than most guys. Foreheads.
Most guys riskers in the league. It's fucking insane.
Thank God you know something. God bless his mother for raising him, right?
Cause I'll tell you right now with his backhand,
thank God he knows how to treat a woman. Cause if he didn't Jesus Christ,
he would make OJ look like a fucking cub scout. All right,
so game three is coming up. Definitely check that out.
And a, and with that,
here's some of the people's favorite Monday morning podcasts, moments,
MMP moments. That's what Andrew wrote. Oh,
we should have like the little big eyed smiling kids here. Um,
douchebag of the week, Brad, remember that? Um,
don't care enough to find the link.
But when Nia gave white people credit for creating the jug instrument,
it was incredible. Uh, that was funny.
Oh then the classic member Granny fucking water at poor best,
it's probably still getting weird looks for those who don't know what granny
water was, this guy was playing some fucking game.
It's kind of seemed like it was old maid but a you didn't want it.
Like if you played the granny water card, you fucked everybody else in the game.
So it came as time to play it and he's with his girlfriend and they're playing
with the parents and out of nowhere,
for whatever reason he decides to give him the Monday morning podcast and throw
in the f word. And when he played the car, he just went granny flood in war
and there was just dead silence. And then he tried,
tried to have to sit there and explain it to everybody.
The it's grantee fucking water listener story from last year.
I think another one, grainy fucking water.
The infamous Rosebowl story had me in stitches at work. That was the time when,
uh, we got to put together a greatest hits.
We really got to do that.
That was the first rose bowl that we went to when we stumbled in there.
And I fucking lost my balance.
And there was an old woman in front of me and I had to like,
and my forum was in her back and she was kind of leaning forward and I was just
sitting here going, I'm sorry.
And no one helped me up cause he was so horrified by the condition I was in.
The only way for me to get up was I had to push off of her, folded her in half.
Oh God. I'd always get this weird feeling in my stomach whenever I don't have,
I, I hate that I did that, but I, I did, I apologize.
Whoever's grandmother that was, but I made whatever. She's
a little more flexible, you know, enjoy the last, you know,
third of her life maybe. Um,
another person rose bowl story with Joe Barnick and the old lady who kept
getting angry and calling her husband to threaten you, mark. No,
she wasn't an old lady. She was younger and that was the time she made fun of,
she made fun of Joe Barton x knows Janie had a big nose and he just looked to
her and said, you need to lose about 30 pounds before you talk to me bitch.
And I was just like, Oh God, all right, we're getting kicked out.
And then she said, she's like, mark, did you hear what he said? Right.
So the guy turns around to square off with Barnick Barton.
He just looks at him and use his big as a fucking Pittsburgh linebacker.
So the guy takes one look at Bart Nick and then starts fucking yelling at me and
started threatening to throw me down in the field. Yeah, you fucking pussy.
Yeah, you go right past bar nick and you go to old fucking balls. Care Top.
All right. I'm a new listener. Eisa his, his favorite moment.
You asking Nia how she's so loud wearing slippers and she's saying that's why
she's angry with you. That's love. And you go, I'm all right. Another one,
you answered a question about a parrot like three years ago that it had me
crying, laughing at my job. I got in trouble. I'll try to find it.
I love how vague these are. This is just as vague. Um, oh, this person like the,
for me, I just feel the Kardashians. They,
the Kardashians could literally watch a baby starve to death and then then they
would be crying, you know, fanning their fucking eyeliner so it doesn't,
you know, smear going. Like for me,
I just felt so sad because for me, um,
it has to be that or the Colby 11. Oh God,
Kelly Olynyk in those fucking Colby eleven's was the worst thing I ever saw.
A when you said Corey Felman was the Lee Harvey Oswald of the robot.
Oh, I had to pull over. I was laughing so hard. I didn't even,
it doesn't even make sense to me anymore. Um, anyways,
let's see. Don't blow it. Keep it simple. Count your money.
I don't even know what that is. Uh, when you did the ad for draft kings,
one guy won $1,000.
One guy's given hand jobs for rent money or something like that. Oh yeah,
that's right. I called that thing out for fucking being legalized gambling.
Um, what else? TCU. Come on. Frogs,
dude. I called it barefoot bitches. There's too many to remember.
I'm still working my way through the older ones. I,
this isn't really making me feel good that you guys remember all this shit.
All right. Here's another one.
One of the best moments was when you told the story of going to the basketball
game and they kept playing that everybody clap your hands.
That's right. And it was all that crazy shit going on. Al. Everybody loves this.
Read old zip
a nature's box. Yeah, I fucked that one up.
I called it,
it was nature box was the name of it and I thought it was like possessive
nature's box. And I was like, you going down on Mother Nature? Needless to say,
that was one and done read and are full refund.
Um, at some point we should put,
I want to put together all the fucking one and done reads that I've had, um,
under the clip. Didn't make a dime off those counts. All right. Um, oh,
the Monday morning podcasts. Nia,
did you money or did you hear about Paula Abdul? She was like, what?
I was like, she's a former backup dancer for the Lakers and now a big pop star.
She thought she'd died. I did it better the first time. Anyways. Uh,
when you told Nia about not checking out, funniest thing ever.
Oh yeah. When I don't check out at hotels, um, I just walk out. I'm done.
Done with you fucking people. Uh,
when you compare it Harry Truman to the guy from Shawshank.
Am I being up two or your last draftkings read. All right.
The Charlie Murphy one. No. Yeah. Yeah. That was a,
that was a sad one. But a happy, the happy memories. Uh, the Yoko Ono rant,
strawberry pubes. That's from the a, the Joe Rogan on it. Read.
Uh, anytime you talk about cool cars,
anytime you lean away from the Mike and yell like a, we're all human.
Some of us are good. Most of us are cons. Oh, the big tears. Big Tears.
When Nia cried in, um, where were we? Italy. I didn't know how to comfort her.
I just kept going. I was hugging her and she was crying.
She had like the biggest tears coming out of her eyes,
like just fallen on my hands, like rain dropped. I was like her from behind,
you know, she, she hit her head.
That's why she bent down to pick something up and it was a shelf and she hit her
head so fucking hard. My, my, even my eyes like,
just watered like holy shit and I didn't know how to comfort it.
So she was crying. I just, I just started reporting. But what was going on,
I was just going, ah, was just going big tears. Tears.
Uh, all right. As a stoner, I find your anti weed rants hilarious.
I get so mad that I start hyperventilating. A, the lovely Nia. Everybody.
Eds, n not m, it's not me. It's near like Nancy, uh,
Nia story about hitting her head in her big tears, big tears. All right.
We said that one. Okay. Uh,
you said Rick Flare wouldn't have come up that fast.
I don't even know what that is. Colby.
Eleven's why are you going to Indianapolis,
Bill all that fucking freak from the plane. Um,
let me see. Friends,
trying to get the rat out of your new house story is an all time favorite.
Anytime there's a zip. Oh yeah. When we were renting that house,
when I got the fucking kitchen redone, um,
another fucking zillion dollars I put in this house and never going to get back.
Uh,
the one time you were talking about those two guys eating shit while riding this
and motorcycle,
the skateboard crashing is the funniest story you've ever told that needs to be
an ana. Oh my God. They, we should animate that. Yes.
So right at time I saw that fucking guy in Griffith park coming down and he
wasn't dressed like a skateboarder and it was like seven 30 in the morning.
You know, when I was walking my old dog Cleo, Oh, I missed that dog.
I'm going to see her again next month. I just view with like,
she's in college and I still always got to visit her. I'm, look,
I love that dog and I'm fucking going to be there someday.
When she takes her final breaths, I'm going to fucking be there. Um, anyways.
Yeah.
So I was walking my dog and this fucking guy came by like the biggest hill in
Griffith park and he was just dressed in street clothes and it started wobbling.
Oh my God. A new fucking reference here.
Like in a MotoGP the tank slap when it starts fucking oscillate and you know,
and all of a sudden they, they can't get it to stop.
He started doing that shit and just like, I don't know,
I'll try and find the clip because I was more vivid when I just saw it.
It was one of the fucking most insane wipeouts.
It easily could have taken over the agony of defeat, um,
in wide world of sports. Um, anyways. Um,
what else? How many six year olds could you kill before they took you down?
You know, I was actually thinking about animating that recently,
but after all the fucking psycho horrible shit that's happened in the world
since I did that used to be funny, you know?
And that's the world we're living in. It's not funny anymore to me.
All right Doug Flutie heckling story about a friend who takes things too far,
may be cry laughing at the gym. No idea which episode that was. Oh yeah,
that was a buddy of mine who didn't know how to talk shit.
I'll tell you that one quickly.
Doug Flutie came back playing for the bills and we're sitting in the end zone
seats and I'm, everybody's like, heckling Doug.
Flutie gone a kill the midget eight. Doug, you're too small, blah blah, blah,
blah, blah. And my buddy wanted to get in and all this shit talk and Ah,
you know, go back to the CFL.
Everybody's just trash and him and my buddy doesn't know where the line is.
And he also studiers starters and out of nowhere he just goes, hey, hey, hey,
hey Flutie.
I hope your kid dies in everybody in the end zone who was hammered immediately
sobered up just from like ugh. And everybody just sat just like, dude,
what the fuck? Fucking brutal.
All right.
Which also used to kind of be amusing to me until now I have a kid now I'm just
kind of like, yeah, that really wasn't really funny that I Jason Marks,
I don't know what that one is. Draftkings final read. And lastly,
but not leastly don't wear diff. No nowhere to find the link.
But the one that introduced the great Pohlad add,
Paul Versey where you guys debated time travel. Oh, that was a good one.
That was a good one, man. Alright, let me read,
I got time here to read a couple of, ah,
a couple of questions here for the week. All right. Military, Virgin,
uh, dear bill of the boar. B U. O. R. E.
I don't know what that means unless you podcasts all the time.
I also from time to time, uh, appreciate your standup comedy.
Okay. Oh, that was a nice back here to compliment.
I listened to your podcast all the time.
And also from time to time appreciate your standup comedy. You know,
it's all right from time to time he makes me smile.
I am from New Hampshire and your video tour of Hampton beach was right on the
money. I am writing to you about my best buddy in the military.
We are both in the service as we became friends. He confessed,
he confessed that he's a virgin at the age of 32 over the past two years since
I've known the guy who refers to play video games and eat dunkaroos than going
out in public tonka ruse. What the fuck are those? Um,
he's an exceptionally funny kid and has no problem making good impression on
strangers or even a lady.
He just cannot reach women in a sexual way right now.
He stationed in Europe in good shape, has a Badass job,
speaks French and is generally charismatic guy.
He has every reason to be doubt drowning and ladies and can even use the foreign
card. But as I check in with them,
he still hasn't gotten out from behind the 60 inch plasma TV.
I don't know what his problem is because he would always be bitching about
wanting a girlfriend and think he may be whacking it too much. Uh,
the new echo epidemic.
And another tidbit is that he will turn to heavy drinking,
which actually helps to open him up.
I can tell he's not satisfied being sig single and using alcohol,
but will not take the initiative to break the cycle.
I'm pissed because he's not using the golden opportunity to slay over there and
he's just disrespecting and it's just disrespectful to the rest of us.
That's fucking hilarious. Um, yeah man, he seems,
I would say that he should probably go to therapy and work out whatever is his
hang up is because um,
there could be a lot of shit that he's sitting on and um,
yeah, that's sad. I feel bad for that guy. You know what I mean?
Would be one thing. Like some people are just naturally like loners and asexual,
whatever and they don't want to be out there, but whatever his deal is,
you know, be a sad thing.
If somebody wanted to find love and they couldn't find love,
that guy should be crushing it.
If he could speak French and he can speak English like that. France,
that's your whole fucking world over there.
Even if you went to England and they don't give a fuck that you can speak
English cause so today, but if you go, so bust out some French, Bam.
You crushed the that. Yes. And he's a man in uniform. Dude, this guy,
he's like fucking like three different porno fantasies for women.
Um, he's got a, what is he going to do next?
Start clean and poles delivering pizzas. Yeah. There's no reason for it.
I would tell you buddy, that he should go talk to somebody, um, about it.
But it's kind of difficult if he's drowning himself in
booze and dot's a delicate thing and it's very difficult to get somebody to go
get help and B, they have to want to do it themselves. So, um,
okay.
But you're a good Fred back cause you actually give a shit. All right.
Conspiracy theory. Sorry, I'm rushing through this.
I'm coming up on an hour in these fucking gas line.
People are going to be showing up soon. Conspiracy theory. A bill.
What do you think of the flat earthers?
It's a growing movement of people who think we're being lied to about the shape
of the earth.
Do you think this is something you would have bought into in your earlier more
intense conspiracy days? No, I wouldn't.
You fucking cunt all you guys. This is what I hate about conspiracy theory.
Conspiracy theory is, is everybody gets lumped into the,
people think the moon is made out of cheese and that there's shapeshifters and
lizard people. Okay.
All I was saying is that the fucking Federal Reserve is a privately owned
corporation, which is a fucking fact.
Okay. I'll say things like,
I don't think that the government or the corporations give a shit about the
people in Iraq because I saw the way they treated the people in New Orleans.
They don't give a fuck about them.
They don't give a shit about those people over there. Okay. So I don't buy that.
That's, that's the level that I go to. Alright. I don't take it to this.
This is what I would say to those fucking flat earth people. Okay, okay.
Let's just say the earth is flat, then.
Wouldn't all the ocean waters just run off the end of it?
Why isn't that happening? How do you explain that?
I would love to talk to a flat earth person. You don't want to be like, well,
why don't you guys do a startup and get yourself a little fucking rocket?
Go up in the fucking air. It's like, have you ever fucking flown in a jet?
You Jackass. You can look out the window and Oh,
you'd see the roundness of the earth.
Um,
I dunno, but you know what? I want to fucking watch videos of it.
I want to hear what they think flat earthers are actually more ridiculous than
people trying to explain.
Believe in like a a creationism or whatever. I believe in Adam and eve,
you know,
Adam and Eve to white people that somehow created Asians and black people and
all that type of shit. I don't fucking get all that. Well actually,
you know something. Yeah, I don't, you know what? I think I actually believe,
believe what that type of shit. I actually think that, uh,
I watched one of those Neil degrasse Tyson things and he said, you know,
we actually came out of trees and I was just like, you know,
what is fucked up is that is at least I can look at a tree and be like,
there it is. That is a tree. Get Walk over, I can touch it,
I can climb on it. Um, it actually made more sense to me than um,
yeah.
Then Adam and eve, I mean it's just, I don't know, maybe if you put like Adam,
if Adam and eve was a movie and then the tooth fairy was a movie,
I mean I'd put them in the exact same category and I don't think that that's
right. All right. Conspiracy theory. Oh, I every right.
I already read that one in India. Taking cash out of circulation. Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Bill just read an article about India and it freaked me out a little bit.
Last November, India removed 86% of the country's cash from circulation.
Most people are now using mobile payment options.
And the artists. See, I don't know what that means.
Also goes on to say the article, sorry.
You got the laptop on the floor that there was ATR c I the article also goes on
to say that ATM machines and Bank cars would be obsolete as early as 2020 in
India.
Not having physical money and only using a phone for buying stuff really makes
me uncomfortable. Any thoughts yet?
They're on their way to microchipping all of us and once again everybody's going
to think that's fucking crazy and you'd go on the Internet.
You look at shitheads who work for corporations that are like proud of their
fucking microchip in their level of security clearance that they have. No,
they're going to phase out fucking everything.
There's going to be cameras everywhere.
You're going to be fucking microchipped and this is the thing.
It's still not going to be enough control for them.
They still won't feel comfortable that they had.
That's how bad their fucking you over that.
They need to have that level of fucking surveillance on you.
That's how fucking weird they are. And they want to see what you talk about,
what you jerk off to and all this shit that if it's fucking beyond creepy.
And I hate when something like that gets brought up on like the fucking news and
all in the best the news anchor could do is kind of widen their eyes like okay,
that's kind of a, that's going to be interesting.
And then they immediately go to talk to us about some fucking old lady that,
you know, just, you know, made her own jam or some shit.
That's the feel good story to get out of it. No,
it's unbelievably fucking creepy. And um,
I don't know. I have no idea how to stop it.
I have no idea how to fucking stop it because no matter what you do,
people just sit there. Like I watched this thing on,
on the news and they showed a robot talking to a little five-year-old kid and
the robot was going like, if you put me in the closet,
that would make me sad.
And like the robot is preying on the fucking emotions of a five year old kid
like that thinks should be illegal.
Like do you realize how fucked up dairy,
I mean I guess they've always done that with products,
preying on the emotions of kids,
but to just see it in that level of raw form and just sit there and having this
robot lying to a five year old, like it has fucking feelings. Um,
I don't know. Does it mean it was,
everything seemed like it's just really sped up and we are just heading right
over the fucking waterfall. That's, that's what I thinks going to, I don't know.
That's what I believe anyways. Um, I actually, this is my theory.
I believe that this is the upper 1% and that they are going to get us all
microchipped and when they get sick of that shit that they're going to dig in a
sick, the robots on us,
they're going to take us all out and eventually the robots will take over the
upper 1% and um, and not in the way you think. They're not going to kill them.
They just going to be like all looking like supermodels and human beings won't
bang each other anymore cause it's going to be, this can be way more difficult.
You know what I mean?
Be Way more fucking difficult than banging a real fucking human being,
then that will just become extinct. Um, all right. Overrated versus underrated.
Uh, overrating giving a shit bill. I just turned 35,
six months ago and I realized how great life can be when you start to only care
about shit that pertains to you. Oh,
I thought that that's going to be like give a shit caring about your fellow man.
This is completely for me. This is the other way I'm,
I don't care about anything anymore.
And my friends and family say they really enjoy my company more these days.
I wasn't yoga or Tony Robbins. It wasn't yoga. Tony Robbins,
no disrespect to either of them. It was apathy. Uh, alright.
Maybe that's what that fucking 32 year old virgin needs underrated.
Waking up early.
I've been waking up early for the last two years of my life has changed
drastically. Everything I talk about doing, I actually do now,
and I'm in better shape than ever because of that. A, you know what,
I'll throw another one. I'll throw a good fucking underrated out there. Sausage.
I got this great fucking butcher, you know,
a couple towns over and I make the drive. I make the drive.
That's how good this fucking butcher is. And when I go in
there, all I ever looked at was the steaks. I looked at the chops, you know,
the fucking pork chops, the chicken.
And occasionally I would fuck with the fish, but I blew right by the sausage.
I was just, I don't know, I didn't just never was into it. You know, it's weird.
I'll have sausage on pizza, I'll have it in an Omelette,
but I never gave a fuck about it.
So I was on the phone with the lovely Nia and you know,
we've been going there a lot and we were kind of running out of options.
We'd done all the steak shit, we'd done the fucking pork chops.
I don't fuck with veal though. There's no need.
There's no need to do that to an animal, you know what I mean?
Just let the thing run around and give it the old fucking right there, Fred. Um,
anyways, so I was just like, I don't know, what do you want to get?
And I was just, and I was just sort of as I was talking to,
I looked over at the sausages
right? And there was one that looked like this fucking giant,
like a black Porno Dick. Right? So I look at, I go, what the fuck is that?
And it said it was short ribs, sausage with cheese.
So I said, I go Nia to these, got these fucking
Porno Black Dick looking sausages here that say the short rib with cheese.
She goes ghettos. Right?
And I don't know if that sounded delicious or just, she's sick of being with me.
But anyways, I got two of them. Right.
And this is really just become some big sexual thing. No,
my wife did not have a threesome with them. We actually had them for dinner.
So anyways, uh, we came home, cooked those fucking things up in the skillet,
made some pasta and a little bit of fucking sauce for it.
And uh, it was fucking delicious.
And now I'm now I'm all about it.
Now I'm just thinking once again, I want to on the big green egg,
I want to learn how to fucking make a pizza, right? Maybe just cheat.
Get the fucking pizza dog and make a good enough sauce.
I get some fresh cheese and I'll go down the street. Get the fucking Pono Dick
fucking sausage, right? Pull a [inaudible] Lorena Bobbitt, chop it up,
put it on the fucking damn. Sorry. You know, an underrated, you know,
it's a different,
underrated trying to talk about sausage and not going into the porn world.
Um, I mean when he went to d fucking Laney,
he looking at it said giant fucking meat. All right,
that's the podcast at 10 year anniversary.
I want to thank all you guys for listening.
This podcast in podcasting in general has changed comedians lives.
It's such a great way to connect with you guys. Promote our shows.
I'll be at hilarity Tuesday and Wednesday. Um,
I've had such a great time doing this. It's actually helped my stand up and a,
I'm gonna continue doing as long as you guys fucking listen. All right.
That said, here's to another 10 years. I'm a porno sausage. Yeah, Dad.
Zip. All right. I'll check in.
You don't take any shit. Go fuck yourselves,
and I'll check in on you on Thursday. All right. See you.